[Applause]
eight years ago today
the Denver Nuggets introduced Michael
Malone as their head coach
the moment he arrived he established a
culture and an identity that would take
the Denver Nuggets to places they've
never belonged before
and here we are
no coach in history of the Denver
Nuggets has more playoff wins than
Michael Malone
[Music]
[Applause]
he came into this world as the son of a
coach but in these playoffs he became
the lager's daddy
[Applause]
[Music]
put that in your pipe and smoke it
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
championship
[Music]
[Applause]
so my first thank yous to you the fans
stay with us
stand with us I love you I appreciate it
my second thank you cronky family
standing Josh love you
appreciate it
and then over there somewhere
my wife
Jocelyn my two beautiful daughters stay
stay away from them now my two people
doors over there
I love you guys
[Applause]
yeah we could not have accomplished this
without you
you're a part of this
I've dreamed about this day since I got
here eight years ago
so I want to say nuggets Nation I love
you
nuggets Nation let's do it again we're
not satisfied
we don't want one we want two
we don't want one we want two we don't
want one we want two
and the guys behind me
17 players
for Stan and Josh cronke Calvin booth
and the 17 players I got guys like
DeAndre Jordan
I got guys like Jeff Green
okay guys like ish Smith
they've been around this league a long
time
[Applause]
and they helped us get here
I got kcp
a new nickname two wings
two wings
I got guys like Bruce Brown come here
Bruce
rules
hey yo tell me
is Bruce will be going anywhere hell no
and no hell no hey we running this [__]
back we ain't running this [__] back oh
yeah come on
hey hey
how about how about a rookie
how about a rookie
winning a championship in college
Jefferson nuggets and helping us from
the chip Christian Brown come here man
Christian man
this dude
he's a bad man bad man
I love him I love them
[Applause]
when we win a championship
it's 17 players strong
it's a coaching staff it's the front
office
it's the ownership but more importantly
as all of you
to celebrate today for 500 000 strong
means the world to me
my mother my father my wife my kids it's
just this real moment and I got one
thing y'all want to do it again
I can't hear you go wanna do it again
I can't hear you y'all want to do it
again let's do this let's do this
dynasty Dynasty Dynasty I love y'all I
love y'all and I love y'all
vision
[Applause]
all right Denver
thank you for that intro Katie wengie
the biggest nuggets band in history
Katie take us home Katie come on hey
give it up to Katie Wiggy everybody
all right Denver now it's time to hear
player's voice
he started as a kid from Kitchener that
believed he could be more
Jamal Murray told us the performances we
saw back in the bubble back in 2020 that
was just the beginning for him
he told us that he would come back even
better
he told us just wait and see what this
team can do when they're healthy
all those Hills that he ran in the cold
days in Canada
the comeback
The Comeback that was so much greater
than the setback
it all led him to right here the arrow
on Target in Denver Colorado
standing on
a world champion
and no stage has ever been too big for
Jamal Murray
[Music]
hey Channel come on up here
[Applause]
yes sir
yeah
I appreciate it everybody
I appreciate everybody
you know what I'm saying we really did
this y'all really did this
y'all give me energy
we give you energy
and we test for life
champions for life
and with that I'm gonna bring out
um
somebody special
um I'm gonna bring out the two-time MVP
Finals MVP Western Conference MVP The
League MVP
Nicola Jokers Young
[Applause]
hey uh
you guys know he stat pads right
and you guys know he didn't win a third
in a row MVP because
the voters didn't want to vote for him
is an amazing player player but I hope
you all know him an attire their
daughter their brothers their family
they are a huge part of Denver so let's
give it up for Nicole yogic and family I
love you
[Applause]
you hear me yeah
okay okay okay
thank you thank you though uh you know
that I I told that uh I don't want to
stay on Parade but I [__] want to
stay on period
[Applause]
this is amazing this is uh if you're all
going to remember this our whole lives
and uh and when we see you guys that uh
came out on the streets and actually
this one is for you we love your Denver
this one is for you thank you guys
foreign
[Applause]
last person I want to speak
this guy's been in the NBA for 16 years
this guy had no idea that his career
will continue with his heart
let me tell you something about Jeff
Green he's all hard
all hard every day
and for me and everyone on the stage
wouldn't that satisfied with one who
wants another one out there
[__] that I can't hear you oh it's
another one
let's go all the way back
[Applause]
this guy right here
is not only a great player
he's a great person
a husband father and I couldn't be more
thankful to have him on our team I want
Jeff Green to close this out because
he deserves this so please please
let's give a huge round of applause for
Uncle Jeff
[Applause]
[Music]
well I wasn't I wasn't expecting that
one
but uh
all I got to say is
[Applause]
thank you guys it was a great season
grinding season you guys support God is
on the way and we appreciate you guys we
did this did this for you guys the city
of Denver
we did it for you
my teammates I love you guys I've always
16 long ass years for this
I love you guys coach
Jamal Joker DJ ish you old okay I won't
say that
my man Casey two times
help me out baby
yo we're gonna we're gonna close out I'm
losing my voice right now but
we're gonna close out I'm gonna count it
three and we're just on gold nuggets you
know so I won the whole crowd I want
everybody to chant it
we Champions we did this for y'all 47
years man for a championship man
we wanna
we wanna celebrate this with y'all and
enjoy this with y'all so I'm accounting
three and we're gonna go nuggets one
two three
[Applause]
last one I promise you last one
listen for everybody out there
every night in that locker room we won a
game we say something special
we talk about family we're a family
we're gonna lose and all you guys ladies
are part of that family so on three
we're gonna say family on three and I
want to hear it loud all right y'all
ready
are you all ready are you all ready
yeah
a family on three folks one
two
three
[Applause]
[Music]
get your gas though it's your dad so hey
we love y'all we love y'all thank you
very much this is all a collective it's
everybody it's everybody in the city
this is for the whole city thank you
guys so much thank you we love y'all man
we gonna run this bad we're gonna run it
out
job
[Music]
[Applause]
I gotta I got a question for y'all
[Music]
one question one question one question
one more year
[Applause]
you heard it here first
nuggets fans Make Some Noise one more
time
for your 2023
NBA world champion Denver
[Applause]
oh oh